that's rad then what a good reveal what
good filmmaking i like it i think
something slipped through did the frame
rate just drop yes
there are parts of the movie that just
go to 12 frames per second i think it's
a cg face i don't think this is actually
real i have no problem with this i have
a million problems with this we've seen
the agents dodge bullets they're
supposed to smear
thanks to heel for sponsoring this video
stick around so you can find out how to
get started with their complete protein
package hey everybody welcome back to
another episode of visual effects
artists react i'm back i was on
paternity leave i had a baby my second
baby and then christmas happened and now
here we are it's a pleasure to be back
i'm looking forward to seeing some vfx
clips with you guys i actually i had all
this time to get all these great clips
oh man yeah
so that's what you were doing
you were getting clips farming clips i'm
excited to talk about the matrix the new
matrix movie the mattress i felt
personally insulted
i seriously did okay tomorrow when i see
it in the theater i'll uh let you know
what my thoughts are as well so wait are
you about to get spoiled right now no
i've got solutions for that as long as i
scream loud enough i won't be able to
hear what's happening or concentrate my
quick review is that i enjoyed the movie
i think i connected with it on a very
different level from everyone else that
being said there are some issues with it
and we're going to look at some of them
today there's one scene in particular
that has talked about is having not good
vfx and that was the train sequence so i
figured let's jump in with that
set and setting what happened to
morpheus he's a computer program now
what don't ask questions if you don't
spoilers sam okay sounds good we're
watching on mute because all you need to
see are the visuals perfect yeah these
visuals are pretty nuts can you not see
through those they're spoiler blocking
glasses it filters the whole scene
through except the spoilers that
anti-spoiler glare
they're on a train where is this train
on a green screen
these guns digital guns they don't look
very good i think something slipped
through did the frame rate just drop yes
there are parts of the movie that just
go to 12 frames per second only john wu
can get away with 12 frames per second
yeah and it's like during goods moments
so what's the first thing that jumps out
to you here niko the first thing that
jumps out to me is just like the
complete mismatch with the outdoor light
versus the indoor light of the train
this is like a big challenge with green
screen sets that they fix with the
volumetric stages for like mandalorian
is that they're approximating what the
background is going to be but they don't
know what the background is going to be
that hasn't been done yet if you look
outdoors you can see it's perfectly
exposed you can see all the colors you
can see the blue sky there's parts are a
little hazy which is weird considering
it's not actually that bright but yet
the amount of light that's hitting the
inside of the train it doesn't match up
with how dim effectively the outside is
i mean it's bright but it's it's well
exposed and you still have these really
bright lights shining into the train
realistically if they wanted this
interior lighting to match better with
exterior it needed to be like a lot
closer to sunset like more like one
directional lighting a lot more shadow
there's a few things that are just kind
of like they look off to me and i can't
tell why so like there's motion blur on
the electrical posts and on the trees
and whatnot but there's like a weird
sharpening going on out there too the
characters in the foreground filmed
against the green screen have a lot of
motion blur they're probably filmed at a
one over 48 shutter maybe one over 60
shutter the background does not have the
same amount of motion blur it has motion
blur but not as much as the foreground
characters probably because if it had as
much motion blur as the foreground
characters if it was a one over 48
shutter for the background those
telephone poles would be invisible when
your traditional shutter speed is like a
1 over 48 it's basically half and double
at the same time so you have a motion
blur here and then equal distance and
then
the image appears again whereas here
when you just look at the telephone pole
it like jumps about tripled a quarter of
that distance so it instantly goes oh
high shutter speed saving private ryan
you know like stylized it feels
different than the footage itself so
there's a instant mismatch it's probably
a decision to let you still see the
things in the background but that
decision breaks the reality of the scene
and now you really feel the green screen
separation what was the other scene that
you wanted the new patrick harris bullet
time sequence oh stop it stop it that
sounds so bad no that's that's not what
you think it is it's not what you think
it is
deja vu right so they want to be like
everybody's swimming slow motion except
for
neil patrick harris
but our frame rate doesn't match for
some reason it's just so inconsistent
bullet time
i know it's like now he's full frame
right but the background spark still had
like motion blur trails and now he's
like sneery because it looked like what
they did was they shot it at a slow
frame rate with a really really high
shutter so you end up with a little bit
of that stop-motion look with everything
being blurred i have no problem with
this i have a million problems with this
because all i know is that we've seen
what that's supposed to look like and
this is what it looks like we've seen
the agents dodge bullets they're
supposed to smear they've literally done
it before and they could have used their
own reference to do this scene and not
make it distracting feels like they had
one day to go like what's an idea and
then one day to shoot it and that sucks
a matrix movie deserves better than that
so there's a problem happening here
which is exposure and color grading so
it looks like they had too much light on
neil patrick harris's face and they had
to pull it down so you're getting kind
of this gray washed out look on his skin
they are lacking color because they
pulled the brightness down and just it
wasn't quite exposed with enough data to
still have good color there so then when
you get into this next sequence where he
steps around keanu reeves and is clearly
rotoscoped from a separate take it
really stands out if there's even like a
touch of like edge feather on his face
and there's like literally edge feather
yeah it's the black multiply edge
feather using edge feather to like blend
your edges i can get by with like
somebody doing that for like a youtube
video but when it's a close-up of an
actor's face in a big budget film which
has the word matrix in the title
it feels really janky i find myself
really wanting to look at the scene
where they walk through the mirror
because i feel like they did all the
mirror stuff so well
[Music]
that looks great right that's great look
at how they're getting the reflections
of her from behind no it's pretty
obvious how they did it there's a hole
in the wall
and they probably have a camera back
there maybe let's assume that that is
the flat plane there measure the angle
between this camera and the plane of the
wall and that is the angle that you have
to be from the other direction on the
other side of the hole in the wall
filming that way which is basically what
you did in your portal trick shots video
you know you're always finding out well
if we were looking through the portal
from the other side the camera would
have to be over here in your
extrapolated position same type of
effect but with a portal what you would
see there is different but it's the same
type of thinking but what blows me away
here is the proximity like the actual
point of contact with the mirror you're
getting like very nice proper mirror
reflection that's kind of a hard thing
to fake unless you do your math
perfectly and have your camera put in
the exact right spot it should be yeah
exactly we've seen people do math
properly with mirrors in the past darby
o'gilly it's a mirror
that's all dolls a mirror this is my
point
okay
i love it
he's like the gold standard of mirror
effects i know but i know what you're
saying i know you're saying like that
footage only can get you so far you know
there's still like a level of
rotoscoping you have to do on the actor
as it's passing through this mirror
element the ripples allow the camera to
see some obscured stuff that the camera
can't actually see normally and to get
that effect you have to then project
this stuff in 3d space so that you can
have the proper reflections like part of
that mirror there with the wave is now
reflecting perfectly back to the camera
we should technically see the reflection
of the camera there you do see some of
the wall of the room in that reflection
yeah and we see some of the hand kind of
reflecting back there and the crazy
thing about mirror effects is that it
seems really intuitive it seems obvious
how you would do it but then when you
actually go through and try to do it it
doesn't work and you're like left
scratching your head going why doesn't
this work hey guys what's your new
year's resolution subscribing to
gonna be my new year's resolution
anyway uh speaking of the matrix let's
look at breaking bad
so breaking bad is a movie that's not
exactly known for the visual effects but
here we have the chicken man right at
the end right before he goes over to the
stars in the war and he gets blown up
is this the scene where she command gets
hurt it's a far cry from that
i forgot about that this is the coolest
villain in the entire show and this is
his final scene and there's a really
interesting thing at play for how they
uh kill off this character spoilers
sorry
whoa big practical explosion pretty
sweet
whoa
that's rad that's super cool it's pretty
sweet right that's super cool that what
a good reveal what
good film making i like it we've seen
this effect before with the dark knight
you know uh two-faced there it's very
guttural
effect to do because you're like this is
not natural yeah it's weird to see holes
in the human body but also like if the
camera pushes up there and parva's cheek
is missing so you get a completely
different profile than what you're
expecting that stuff triggers you a
little bit and there's an extra little
detail that i love his eye
looks where his other eye does oh that's
so cool that's so gross
little muscles moving in there
i never noticed that that's that makes
it so much grosser they also did have
some practical prosthetics on his face
and in visual effects not only do they
have to remove that but they have to
remove pretty much the entirety of the
head so that they can have a clean plate
so that where it actually is kind of
eating into his head they can replace
that and the fact that it's very hard to
tell what is real versus what is not is
a testament to how good the execution of
this effect is they were meticulous
about how they were going to go about
doing this effect because they knew that
they're going to be doing this as a
visual effect and they wanted to support
it with the prosthetic makeup and this
is a different argument than say doing
like monster creature effects like in
the thing you know where they replaced
all of it with cg and people had mixed
feelings about that that is like a
different scope from what this is this
is okay to replace that sort of stuff
with cg it all works towards making a
better final product not to mention it
also lets you scan something in 3d so
don't have somebody go there and model
it the whole time you just scan it and
then there's your 3d element to work off
of this is a shot that was specifically
requested in the comments and i was like
you know what you're right so if you
have any other ideas for shots for us to
look at leave a comment down below we'll
take a look yeah even if they seem
obvious i can't believe we haven't done
this one i know right this has been
around for years i've known about it and
those little reminders you leave for us
in the comments helps so much so you've
seen our debunking videos right someone
sent me a ufo video and i cannot figure
it out we have a deep cut a anonymous
user has given us the raw footage to
what appears to be a real ufo sighting
and so far from what we can tell we
can't figure it out so we're going to
debunk it and check out that video here
on corridor crew hey maybe you can
figure it out so come join us in that
video tomorrow yeah it comes out
tomorrow so subscribe so you don't miss
it
so speaking of breaking bad the witcher
this is going to be a very similar type
of effect the reason i wanted to pull up
the witcher here is there's a little bit
of a redemption arc here we we really
roasted the first rose the first witcher
but with the second season it looked
like they kind of either turned up the
quality meter or just the money meter or
so i don't know what they did
like everything about the second season
is way better and definitely an
improvement over the first season
especially this effect in this scene a
fire for my guests
and you my dear oh wait i've seen this
guy okay i know what you're talking
about here then didn't the actor come
out and say that it was all prosthetic
well let's watch it let's watch it and
think about it a little bit
nice when they drop all the food i can
just imagine like 10 stage hands on
ladders above holding a dish they all go
at the same time
doesn't this remind you of like the best
prosthetic you've ever seen from like an
80s movie or like a 90s movie or
something it has that prosthetic look to
it you can kind of see it with that
sheen on his skin it's like it's not
overly articulated it looks latex rather
than like skin or rendered all right so
just give me your like vfx artist like
all right what's going on here i'll bet
it's a prosthetic that can have a mouth
calm
like most prosthetics in the 80s and
they're using computers and then warp it
babe oh you think so the movie because i
think it's a cg face i don't think this
is actually real so i think it's real
hair on the top of his head and the face
here is added but we're also seeing the
hair from his beard moving there's
interaction there so i don't know how
much of the hair was replaced after the
fact his beard shadow looks like a cg
beard shadow onto his shirt it's got the
kind of like weird ambient softness as
opposed to like specificity ambient
softness yeah gives away shadows it's
just a general soft shadow as opposed to
like a clear like following the contours
of her shirt shadows aren't just your
scene with the brightness turned down
shadows are the absence of one light
letting the other light in so there's
like a blue ambient light in a yellow
direct light and you shade the yellow
direct light it doesn't just get darker
it lets the blue light through of the
ambient light that's still hitting it
that being said it's that's not the sort
of thing that is detracting from the
effect for me like i'm not noticing that
but like when you point out i'm like
okay i guess there is some ambient
softness going on with that shadow it's
just not bad yeah it's a cue i look for
okay well look these are some really
good theories and i think honestly this
discussion is a good testament to how
well it was done and like how well
designed the character is for the actor
playing it as well
his face is motion capture and just
everything around the face is real yep
wow
i called it that's what i said it looks
really good isn't it a good blend so
what they're basically doing is they're
not just filling in the hole they add a
little extra hair to blend in and then
that's basically stamped over the actual
practical hair which is great for
there's all these scenes where it's
backlit with like a fireplace and you're
like what is going on yeah that's nice
that's well done that is smart onset vfx
thinking that's every department working
together costume makeup direction these
are really well done effects yeah that's
really cool this makes me want to watch
the witcher i know same thing that's
exactly what happened to me i saw this
i'm like oh it's witcher time again yeah
are you sad this episode's ending well
on quarter digital.com it's just getting
started with our extended reacts so
check them out there yeah we argue a lot
about the matrix but the show on youtube
is about vfx so if you want to dive more
into that subscribe to the website do
you want to hear what i really think
about the matrix corridor digital.com
that's that's actually pretty soft
that's pretty good that's a pretty good
one
all right guys i'm super excited we just
got some ready to drink fuel you may not
know what that means but last time that
i was with you guys we had heal protein
powder in a bag but this time there's a
ready-to-go drink
strawberry shortcake there's nana
berry we love us some coffee here so
what's better than coffee and protein
combined man we're gonna be pushing off
videos like there's no tomorrow peel is
a 100 nutritionally complete meal it's
full of proteins essential fats
carbohydrates fiber vitamins and
minerals actually 27 essential vitamins
and minerals each bottle contains 20
grams of protein i personally love fuel
because it works with my day perfectly i
work out every single morning before i
come to the studio sometimes the
workouts are at different times i don't
always have time to make breakfast
this is where these bad boys come in
ready to go made meals in a bottle 20
grams of protein so after my workout i
get fueled up there's no cooking there's
no cleanup there's no time wasted i can
come in and get to exactly what i need
to do it tastes like there's way more
than three grams of sugar in there oh my
goodness
that tastes super good i'm a human and i
need some fuel try this chocolate time
to fuel up oh my gosh dude that's
amazing
and it's all plant-based dude
crazy i didn't know plants could make
this
i'm a fool for huel i'll tell ya and it
tastes like a a cinnamon roll that's a
cheat code for life oh that's good come
on now heal
fuel
[Music]
well it looks like the whole crew is on
fuel so we want you to get healed up as
well click the link in the description
and go choose your flavors
if you need fuel fill up with heal
back to the episode thanks for watching
i can't wait to see the matrix tomorrow
i'm super jazzed
and if you want to catch in theaters too
uh you know you're allowed to like it
yeah
i'm only so aggravated by the matrix
because i'm so passionate about the
matrix i usually try not to do this on
this show but i'm being emotionally
honest so right that's what we're
supposed to be like in 2022. a lot of
people agree with you nico but i think
i'm on the list of people that did like
it i like the first half if you like the
movie you're not alone you know that
that's always a great place to be it's
on the list of people who like something
so hopefully i'm on that list tomorrow
[Music]
the end